[Music]
it is time for us to come together time
for us to unite the historic victory of
Manitoba's Premier elect how do you do
I'm W Cano the political challenges he
faces and how he lured
voters also on this Wednesday night the
final farewell to a fallen RCMP
officer the regimental funeral for
Constable Rick O'Brien former crypto
King pour the fraud case against the
Bitcoin Bubble Boy the lessons for
investors plus the real problem with
deep fague videos I am not Morgan
Freeman how quickly AI technology is
advancing and the legal
[Music]
loopholes global national with Donna FZ
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight in Manitoba where
voters have made history electing a new
premier
wob Cano a 41-year-old former rapper
journalist author and University
administrator upset the progressive
conservatives winning an NDP majority
making him the first provincial First
Nations Premier in
Canada this is the most difficult thing
that I've ever done in my life and the
real work hasn't even begun yet so I'm
going to treat this job with the utmost
of reverence and the humility that I
believe will be necessary to serve you
the people of Manitoba and of course I
hope to make a a positive contribution
for all Canadians as well canoe made
lots of expensive promises from fixing
Health Care to making life more
affordable and searching a landfill for
murdered indigenous women our coverage
begins with Melissa rgen in
Winnipeg good morning Manitoba good
morning Canada today is a new day it was
all smiles at the end of a long and
sometimes ugly campaign Tuesday night
wob canoe a former journalist author and
member of the igaming first nation
became Manitoba's Premier designate
making history as the first first
nation's premier of a province Manatoba
did something more Progressive than any
of those big cities ever
did he took the opportunity to address
Youth and those battling addiction I was
given a second chance in
life and I would like to think that I've
made good on that
opportunity and you can do the same
making history wasn't what he campaigned
on the NDP hammered away at improving
health care and affordability while the
conservatives made crime and parental
rights their priorities say that we
don't have to agree on everything in
order to do the big things together one
of the most divisive issues in this
election a search of the Prairie green
landfill for the remains of at least two
murdered indigenous women manitobans
were split 47% in favor 45% against the
NDP said they would search while the
conservatives said they would not I am
extraordinarily proud that our Province
chose to rise above that sort of
division on this national day of action
for missing and murdered indigenous
women and girls Ottawa was quick to
commit an additional $740,000 to further
assess the feasibility of a landfill
search I think um all governments um
need to be part of this process uh from
a federal perspective I've been very
clear uh that we're in it for the long
haul um and we will work with the
families at the community impacted as
well as um uh the province of Manitoba
to get to the right answer on this it
will take up to three years and could
cost $200 million with the wheels now in
motion Manitoba Grand Chief Kathy
Merrick says the focus can turn to the
other issues that manitobans care about
I believe in him as a leader and I
believe in him as to what he can do and
what work he can do for all man toin an
uphill battle canoe says he's ready for
what I am proud of is that
manitobans uh rejected that message of
division and you embraced uh a message
of positivity thank you very much
Melissa Rin Global News
Winnipeg David Aken is also in Winnipeg
hovering the election he has some
insights into why the NDP one David well
Donna first thing I don't think we
should really be surprised the NDP one
because they had been leading in the for
about 2 years the progressive
conservatives here deeply unpopular
particularly after the pandemic that
said the NDP did have to design a
campaign and then execute on that game
plan they did just that uh W Cano the
NDP leader uh leading his party in a
second election so some experience there
but WK canu spent almost every day in
the campaign talking about healthc care
and that really was The Sweet Spot as so
far as issues go on the other side of
the Ledger the progressive conservatives
really didn't find a theme more a
message that resonated with voters they
they started out talking about tax cuts
but that was nowhere near the top of
Mind issue for voters and when the
numbers didn't turn we saw some pretty
nasty attack ads attacking the character
of wob Cano attacking the character of
many other new Democrats who got elected
yesterday and so uh are there now some
lessons for political parties elsewhere
well new Democrats here have been using
the phrase the last week or so they say
their success was all about meeting
voters where they are it's a way of
saying uh reading the room right or
getting the tone right it might sound
simple but it can be tough to do and if
we look around the country right now we
see leaders like the NDP Premier MBC
David eie or in Ottawa the federal
conservative leader Pierre PV let's
bring it home they're having strong
support in the polls right now possibly
because they are meeting voters where
they are when it comes to issues around
housing affordability and cost of living
now in New Brunswick Blaine hags may be
just about to call a snap election over
the issue of parents rights and if he
does that he's going to have to ask
himself is he meeting voters in that
Province where they are Donna okay David
aen in Winnipeg tonight
[Music]
thanks a final salute for an RCMP
officer killed in the line of duty in BC
a regimental funeral service was held
for Constable Rick O'Brien today the
51-year-old was shot and killed while
executing a search warrant at a home in
Coquitlam last month O'Brien had
recently marked seven years of service
he'd earned an award for bravery shortly
after joining the
RCMP Neu Gara is in Langley BC where the
funeral took place
Neu Donna at the somber event in this
Arena behind me there was a constant
theme in the speeches in tribute to
Constable Rick O'Brien he believed in
the positive power of his profession we
heard today that one of the reasons
O'Brien wanted to do this job is he
wanted to show kids police officers are
there for them and can be trusted on his
own time he would Dawn a uniform and
visit with young people with the goal of
being a positive influence on their
lives the day of his death O'Brien was
executing a search warrant at a condo
building in the Vancouver suburb of
kitum he was responding from a
neighboring RCMP Detachment along with
other officers when he was shot and
killed the next day a 25-year-old man
was charged with first-degree murder in
O'Brien's death O'Brien leaves behind a
big family his wife and six children
here are some more of the sentiments
shared in the solemn service Rick
O'Brien Was preparing to graduate depo
and start his dream job with the
RCMP one of the Rick reasons Rick wanted
to become a police officer was because
he wanted to show kids that police
officers were there to help and that
they could be trusted This truly was his
dream job and he loved
it but even greater than the love he had
for the the RCMP the love that Rick had
for his kids his family and of course
his
soulmate and the love of his life
Nicole was truly
remarkable this afternoon hundreds in
uniform marched in the procession as
members of the public asked to wear red
for Rick today lined the route a symbol
of how his loss is being felt by so many
Donna N Gara in langle BC
thanks more information is emerging
about the Alberta couple killed by a
grizzly bear in bam National Park
dougles and Jenny guzy both 62 were from
Lethbridge Alberta their nephew says
they were experienced in the back
country they'd been checking in Daily
during their week-long backpacking trip
he says he realized something was wrong
when anos message came through from
their satellite device saying bear
attack bad
these are people who love this area who
love being out
who saw Bears on their on their walks in
this country but those were normal
situations you see the bear in The
Distance you go the opposite way the
bear goes its own way that's not what
happened in this case when a Parks
Canada team reached the area they found
the bodies of the couple and their dog
and an aggressive grizzly bear it was
euthanized Park officials say it was a
25-year-old underweight female bear they
say the couple's food had been hung
appropriately two cans of bear spray
were found at the scene and it's
unlikely we'll ever know the reason for
the
attack the first of an expected five
complainants in the sex assault trial of
Peter niggard appeared in front of a
Toronto jury today the former head of a
fashion business is charged with five
counts of sexual assault and one count
of forcible confinement he's accused of
using his position to lure women and
girls during the 1980s and into the mid
2000s Katherine McDonald was in the
courtroom today in a warning some of the
details of the case are
disturbing the lawyer for Peter nyard
suggested to the first alleged victim
that she only spoke to police in late
2020 after learning about a class action
lawsuit in the US that she thought she
could become part of this is a photo
shown to the jury of a woman who can
only be identified by her initials KR
taken in July 1989 when the 28-year-old
visited a yoga retreat in the Bahamas
waiting for her flight back to Toronto
she met Peter nyard who told her he was
a big-time fashion designer and that he
had a property in the Bahamas and other
Estates elsewhere that December after
niggard invited her to a Rolling Stones
concert she testified niggard locked her
into his bedroom suite at his company
headquarters where he forced her to have
sex on the stand Wednesday KR said she
took a taxi home and told her roommate
she'd been raped but decided against
going to police because nyard was
wearing a condom and it would be his
word against hers and she was a simple
working actor KR told the jury in 1998
she saw an article about nyard and Frank
magazine and confided to a friend that
niggard had raped her on the friend's
urging she went to Police Headquarters
and gave a videotaped statement she
later decided against pursuing charges
saying she was scared and it would cause
her stress in December 2020 she spoke to
police again after they came to her the
crown attorney asked why now KR replied
following the me too movement things
have changed in society and I think it's
time for that type of behavior to stop
it's something that has tainted my life
I want to get it over with defense
lawyer Brian Greenspan suggested she
read a New York Times article in
February 2020 about a civil lawsuit
against niggard in the US and thought
she could be well compensated too
Greenspan the class will go well if Mr
niggard is criminally convicted in
Toronto isn't that fair KR agreed
admitting she is part of the suit but
said she only emailed the law firm
initially to tell them good luck saying
it happened to her too and not believing
she could be part of the suit because
she was Canadian Peter niggard has
pleaded not guilty kather McDonald
global news from crypto King to accused
con artist coming up opening arguments
in the trial of the man accused of
stealing billions from
customers former US president Donald
Trump was in court for the third day of
his civil fraud trial in New York he his
adult sons and the Trump organization
are charged with inflating property
values over a decade today Trump blasted
the judge he called the trial fraudulent
and unjust and then he left sending out
a fundraising email to his supporters
claiming he'd been forced to attend in
fact his appearance is voluntary New
York's attorney general denounced
Trump's rhetoric and said she will not
let anyone subvert
Justice I will not be
bullied and so Mr Trump is no longer
here the Donald Trump show is over this
was nothing more than a political stunt
a fundraising stop and now we can
continue to F go forward with our trial
and we are confident that Justice will
be served the judge issued a gag order
against defendants discussing members of
his staff after Trump attacked one of
the law clerks on social media the trial
of a 31-year-old accused of stealing
billions from customers got underway in
Manhattan today Sam bankman freed is the
founder of FTX once one of the biggest
crypto exchanges in the world the
prosecution says it was all built on
lies while the defense claims bankman
freed acted in good faith Joel senic
takes us through the opening arguments
and the implications of this case for
the crypto
industry Sam bankman freed in court
accused of stealing billions from
customers of his now bankrupt company
FTX Sam bman freed is a huge case FTX
went to be come from nothing to a giant
company it was running TV ads with
celebrities this is a massive case FTX
was a marketplace where you could buy
and sell cryptocurrency prosecutors
alleged bankman freed used customer
money to prop up his own hedge fund buy
luxury real estate and donate to us
political campaigns the 31-year-old
pleaded not guilty to the charges
against him but admitted publicly in the
past to making mistakes in the FTX
collapse he's violated the conventional
wisdom of all criminal defense lawyers
don't talk to anyone keep quiet keep low
keep a very quiet profile lawyers for
bankman freed describe him as a math
nerd who didn't pay attention to risk
management prosecutors argue the former
billionaire orchestrated a scheme to
build an Empire one Canadian crypto
researcher says the case will provide
lessons for the entire industry the SP
SPF case will be looked upon as the sort
of key Milestone narrative that told the
world and investors that you need adults
in the room FTX was operating out of the
Bahamas where bankman freed was arrested
last December the company was previously
based in Hong Kong tightening government
regulation there made the more friendly
regulatory environment in the Bahamas
particularly appealing the net is only
as secure as the weakest jurisdiction
that's allowed to enter and do business
in your country which is why consumers
are urged to do their homework before
putting money into a crypto exchange I
would recommend that Canadians use ones
that that have decided to make the
investment in operating here in Canada
under the regulatory regime bakeman
Freed's trial could last weeks
prosecutors say they will call former
members of his inner circle to testify
against him and if he's convicted he
could face more than a hundred years in
prison Joel senic Global News
Washington the suspect in the murder of
rapper Tupac Shakur made his first court
appearance today in Las Vegas Dwayne
Davis was arrested on Friday after a
grand jury indicted him for murder to
promote a criminal gang Tupac Shakur was
shot and killed in 1996 Davis's
arraignment was postponed for 2 weeks he
is expected to plead not
guilty still ahead why the British prime
minister is putting the brakes on a
High-Speed Rail
[Music]
Project in Croatia crews are trying to
contain a huge fire at a recycling plant
it started early this morning and spread
rapidly sending plumes of thick black
smoke into the air plastic waste and
harmful chemicals are burning and people
have been told to stay indoors and keep
their windows closed it's expected to
take several days to put out the
fire and this was a close call security
camera video from Australia shows the
moment two Backpackers narrowly escaped
an explosion inside a hostel in Sydney
fire and rescue crews say the blast was
likely caused by a faulty electric bike
battery that was charging the building
was evacuated and one of the men seen in
the video was treated for burns on his
leg the UK was once a Pioneer in rail
Transportation it's now fallen behind
some of its European neighbors and today
British prime minister Rishi sunak
scrapped a section of a planned
High-Speed Rail Line in England Redmond
Shannon explains how the pricey Saga
could have some valuable lessons for
similar projects here in Canada the only
G7 country without High-Speed Rail HS
2's new British built bullet style
trains will hs2 is the UK's largest
infrastructure project 500 new bridges
are being built across the route and 100
kilomet of tunnels but as construction
costs have ballooned up to an estimated
$170 billion the Ambitions of hs2 have
been cut back or delayed to save money
it was originally planned to connect
London with England's less prosperous
North to two years ago most of the
Eastern Branch was cancelled now prime
minister rishy sunak has asked the
Manchester section leaving just the
southern leg to Birmingham the right
thing to do when the facts change is to
have the courage to change direction as
the UK economy struggles sunak faced
pressure from within his own party to
make the call at the Tory National
Convention in Manchester sunak critics
say the billions already invested will
now provide little benefit the only way
to make sure you don't overspend on a
project is to finish it the sooner you
get it done and dusted and all the money
spent then that that's when the risk of
overspend disappears the expensive
dilemma could be an important lesson
should Canada ever build High-Speed Rail
something that has been proposed along
the Windsor Quebec Corridor and in
Alberta it's not just other developed
countries countes now that have
highspeed rail it's countries like
Indonesia usbekistan turkey Morocco
Transit analyst ree Martin says one
lesson from hs2 is that going
underground usually means going over
budget in any longdistance project that
we talk about in Canada there's
definitely opportunities to build a lot
of fast line that's away from where
people are living for the most part and
that you can do that effectively
Indonesia opened its first High-Speed
Rail line on Monday that project backed
by money and experience from China
Redmond Channon Global News
London believe it or not next how AI is
making it harder to tell what's
real artificial intelligence feels like
one of those great unknown something
that has the potential to both help us
and hurt us and pretend to be us this
week the world's biggest YouTube Star Mr
Beast had to clarify to his 180 million
followers that he was not offering $2
iPhones but his likeness in a deep fake
video was it's all a scam and as Mike
Dray reports it's getting easier to pull
off I'm not Morgan Freeman and what you
see is not real the likeness is uncanny
and that's becoming a growing issue if
you haven't heard of deep fakes it's
video or audio created by artificial
intelligence with the end goal of
creating something that didn't actually
occur what's up internet I'm north of
the Border a Tom Cruz for example
doesn't create videos for Tik Tok and
while a clip exists of Tom Hanks selling
dental plans the actor himself warned
his fans it's not actually him well
unfortunately we don't live in a perfect
world where everybody's going to use the
technology for good I think that um I
hope that there will be uh more thought
put into how we can actually create like
a a good legislative framework around
how these Technologies can be used with
deep fakes you can conceivably assume
anyone's identity like say John malovich
or what about John Travolta no wait
here's a good one Prince William the
possibilities are as endless as they are
terrifying but yeah some of those like
my English accent are better than others
but the technology which is for the most
part free online is improving all the
time and here's the r there are no
requirements that it be used in any
moral or ethical way you want to keep
your money and your freedom as with most
things AI the laws are still catching up
to the technology in California deep
fakes are banned in politics and
pornography but a gray area still exists
with satire and parody and Canadian
copyright laws protect deep fakes in
certain circumstances as having a social
purpose so obviously there's negatives
in the sort of misinformation category
uh but there's also the opportunity to
do some pretty good political satire a
satire like Justin Trudeau reading a
very anti- trudo book every person in
Canada liked Freedom a lot but the Prime
Minister who ran the country did not the
video is obviously fake and arguably
hilarious but when the coding makes it
too lifelike will it still be funny Mike
Dray Global News
Toronto and that is global national for
this Wednesday I'm Donna FZ there is
nothing fake about tonight's your Canada
it was grown in Richmond British
Columbia it is this enormous pumpkin
78-year-old David Chan grew it in his
backyard he calls it Mama and he drove
down to California with it to enter it
in one of the world's biggest pumpkin
contests turns out mama was the heaviest
pumpkin in the patch 2,212 LBS or more
than 1,000 kog and Chan took home more
than
$27,000 thanks for watching hope to see
you here again tomorrow bye-bye
[Music]
[Applause]
bye